if you could forget a book or a movie
and be able to experience it for the
first time again what would you
choose book or a movie a book or a movie
that's a tough I would say would I get
the same feeling as when I first saw it
because that like if I Saw The Shining
for the first time now and felt the same
scare that I did back then I'd say The
Shining or um Star Wars Star Wars or
Empire Strikes Back I mean the the cool
thing about Star Wars is now when you
get the new Star Wars you get to have
that feeling of like oh it feels like
the first time watching and then you
know uh cuz cuz there's new stories to
be told but but I would go with Star
Wars the first one yeah yeah